[Música]
seguimos hablando de cifras
considerables aquí en el segmento de
economía está conmigo en el estudio Juan
Pablo lucumir Juan Pablo muy buenas
noches bienvenido vamos a comenzar
hablando de una cifra histórica en el
sector de vivienda de Estados Unidos qué
es lo que pasa buenas noches Santiago
pues es la primera vez que en una década
que los precios de las viviendas en la
primera Economía del mundo están cayendo
Y es que por lo menos en 20 grandes
ciudades por los costos de las viviendas
nuevas cayeron en un 0,44% en julio
siendo esta la primera caída desde marzo
de 2012 Pues en esos 10 años Hasta ahora
se ha registrado un importante aumento
de precios Coronado por el Frenesí de
compras de inmuebles tras la pandemia
del covid 19 ahora esto podría
considerarse un pequeño triunfo para los
esfuerzos de la reserva Federal Pues
recordemos que de forma consecutiva el
Banco Central estadounidense ha
realizado aumentos en los tipos de
interés para enfriar la economía sin
embargo
vistas económicos y del sector
inmobiliario mencionan que en realidad
los precios de las viviendas aún están
elevados entonces con los precios
cayendo los estadounidenses empezaron a
comprar más las ventas de las viviendas
nuevas se dispararon un 28,8% en agosto
respecto a Julio y también se superó la
expectativa de ventas para este mismo
periodo pues se espera que pues esperaba
que se vendieran por lo menos 500 mil
viviendas pero fueron
685.000 las viviendas que se vendieron
en ese país momento para comprar
vivienda en Estados Unidos Juan Pablo
reportábamos estas fugas en los
gasoductos del Norte Stream 1 y el North
Stream 2 esto que repercusiones tiene
económicamente pues si el sistema de
gasoducto fue saboteado como asegura
occidente esto equivaldría una escalada
en las tensiones entre Rusia y Europa
luego de que los recientes cortes del
suministro y las acusaciones de que
Moscú utiliza dichos cortes como arma
política a nivel económi los precios del
gas se dispararon con la noticia después
de cuatro días de pérdida los precios de
referencia del gas europeo subieron
hasta un 12% Este martes precios que
recordemos ya estaban elevados debido a
la escasez de este mismo insumo en el
viejo continente con la fuga también
implica un riesgo ambiental pues cada
tonelada de gas natural vertida a la
atmósfera tiene casi 80 veces el impacto
de calentamiento de dióxido de carbono
las autoridades de la zona económica
exclusiva en el mar Báltico y la
administración marítima sueca han
limitado el tránsito de las
embarcaciones así como la velocidad en
la que estas transitan en la zona Por
ende una afectación en el transporte de
mercancía varios líderes mundiales
reaccionaron a la noticia escuchemos
en los últimos meses los mercados
energéticos ya están bajo una gran
tensión a los países del sur global les
ha resultado difícil competir por
energía limitada No sólo en términos los
precios precios crecientes sino a menudo
en términos de disponibilidad lo que hay
son licitaciones pero los países han
tenido licitaciones para las que ni
siquiera obtienen una respuesta de los
proveedores
se acerca el invierno Juan Pablo y
Alemania sigue buscando alternativas
para suministrar energía y una opción
puede ser la energía nuclear y puede ser
alternativa al gas ruso que dicen allí
recordemos que Alemania se había
propuesto en la eliminación gradual de
la energía nuclear para finales de este
año pero con el reciente panorama
energético el gobierno germano consideró
no cerrar dos de sus últimas centrales
nucleares en lo que queda de este 2022 y
ahora permanecerán como reservas hasta
el 15 de abril de 2023 escuchemos
estos elementos clave y luego la ley
posterior garantizará la disponibilidad
de las dos centrales nucleares nécar
bersstein eicer 2 Después del final de
sus periodos operativos a finales de
este año para los meses de enero febrero
marzo y mediados de abril las
autoridades de seguridad los servicios
esta cámara y también los operadores por
supuesto están poniendo su granito de
arena para protegerse para proteger la
infraestructura y para garantizar un
suministro de energía seguro en Alemania
Santiago Pérez usted Se preguntará de
qué dependerá que continúen o no estas
centrales pues Alemania estará
dependiendo del suministro de energía
nuclear de Francia para determinar si
extender la vida útil de estas plantas
Juan Pablo indicadores Cómo les fue a
las principales bolsas alrededor del
mundo las acciones en Wall Street
cerraron en terreno mixto después de una
jornada bastante inestable el nasdaq
reportó unas leves ganancias y a pocos
días determinarse el mes expertos prevén
otro mes con cierres de pérdidas tras el
aumento de las tasas de interés por
parte de la reserva Federal en Europa
los mercados estuvieron en números rojos
luego de que las fugas de gas en el
gasoducto nostrim 1 y 2 como hablamos
hace un momento además de los precios
del petróleo y del Oro que también se
dispararon si vamos a nuestra región
podemos destacar que la Bolsa Mexicana
de valores avanzó Este martes en su
principal indicador y esto ayudó a
romper una racha de cuatro cierres a la
baja sin embargo con el panorama de las
pérdidas de Estados Unidos y la crisis
energética de Europa ya veremos el
comportamiento bursátil para mañana Juan
Pablo Muchas gracias completo reporte de
economía ustedes no se muevan que a
continuación ya viene el debate
[Música]